es gibt tatsächlich einige Städte in
Europa in denen im Mai und Juni 24
Stunden die Sonne scheint ich habe mich
schon länger vorgenommen eine dieser
Städte mal zu besuchen um am eigenen
Leib zu erfahren wie sich das eigentlich
anfühlt also habe ich mich auf den Weg
gemacht in die norwegische Stadt trübsow
und die Erfahrung die ich da gesammelt
habe von wirklich wunderschön viel Spaß
mit diesem Video
und damit ey Leute was geht ab und
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen Video
ich hoffe natürlich euch geht's gut ich
bin fast dabei mein Flug zu verpassen
weil ich hier 8 Jahre gebraucht um einen
Parkplatz zu finden und auf der Autobahn
Unfall war vielleicht bekomme ich den
gar nicht dann ist das Video ich bin
Arsch und ich kann wieder nach Hause
fahren falls ich ihn doch bekomme geht's
weiter ansonsten kurz was wir heute
machen wir fliegen nach vorne so das
soll ganz cool sein da geht die Sonne
nicht unter vielleicht bis gleich okay
Leute ich habe so gerade geschafft hoffe
ich mal zumindest schon gestartet aber
Abflug ist erst in 30 Minuten deswegen
schaffe ich das oder 25 Minuten nur wir
haben ja schon Mai und wer ist jetzt
richtig voll gewesen hätte ich
vielleicht Probleme bekommen wegen
Security Check aber alles easy so
erstmal muss ich noch Auslosung
okay Leute das hätten wir schon mal ich
fliege auf jeden Fall jetzt erstmal noch
osloh da war ich auch schon einmal
musste umsteigen und von da raus geht
weiter nach oben so weil es halt kein
Direktflug gibt es ganz weit oben aber
das wird denke ich ganz entspannt und
wir sehen uns in Oslo wieder
wenn man sich die Straßen so wie in
Norwegen anguckt da fahren echt nicht
viele Autos also man sieht das hier
nicht viele Leute wohnen eigentlich sehr
entspannt
so Leute angekommen in osloh hier war
ich zwar schon mal aber ich werde den
Flughafen ja auch nicht verlassen bevor
wir allerdings weitermachen würde ich
euch gerne den Sponsor des heutigen
Videos vorstellen der ist dieses Mal für
mich überhaupt möglich macht dass ich
soweit reisen kann und so viele coole
Sachen in kurzer Zeit erleben kann weil
wer hätte es gedacht so was kostet immer
eine Menge Geld vor allem in einem der
teuersten Länder weltweit und zwar ist
das egal ein cashbackanbieter mit egal
habe ich auch schon vor einiger Zeit mal
zusammengearbeitet und ich kann euch das
ganze nur wärmstens empfehlen bei was
ist denn schöner als im Internet online
zu shoppen und dann ein Prozentsatz
eures ausgegebenen Betrages über die IGA
App oder über die Website wieder zu
bekommen ja das geht wirklich und vor
allem super unkompliziert egal hat
nämlich mittlerweile über 1800
Partnershops für die die das Konzept
noch nicht ganz verstehen wenn du über
Igel also irgendwo etwas kaufst bekommt
ihr gerade eine Vermittlungsprovision
und davon werden dir direkt bis zu 90%
auf dein egal Konto gutgeschrieben ich
zeige euch hier einmal wie es im Browser
aussieht wenn ihr online shopping über
den Computer oder Laptop macht und über
den Browser ins Internet geht könnt ihr
einfach den IGA Cashback Melder
installieren das geht ganz schnell zeige
euch immer so sieht das aus und dann
erkennt euer Computer sozusagen
automatisch dass sie ein igal-konto
besitzt das heißt wenn ihr über booking
Otto Asos Media Markt Ski in Douglas was
auch immer etwas bucht bekommt ihr
automatisch Cashback ohne irgendwas zu
machen oder ihr installiert euch einfach
die Igel App so wie ich das hier gemacht
habe Klamotten kann man eigentlich immer
gebrauchen bis zu 10 % Cashback auf
about you Cashback wird aktiviert kommt
jetzt der Sommer da kann man immer mal
ein T-Shirt gebrauchen das gefällt mir
eigentlich ganz gut überlegen war nicht
lange bisschen auch was heißt dies das
Ananas und in den Warenkorb okay T-Shirt
ist bestellt 34,90 € und ich blende euch
jetzt hier nochmal Screenshot ein wenn
ich das Cashback erhalten habe hier
booking damit buche ich z.B immer 4%
Expedia auch eine travel App sogar bis
zu 8 % Cashback und ihr bekommt mit
meinem Link der ist unten in der
Videobeschreibung ganz oben anstatt die
üblich 5 € Startguthaben wenn ihr euch
bei egal anmeldet sogar 10 € die ihr
euch noch ganz entspannt auszahlen
lassen könnt also besser geht's nicht
vielen Dank und wir machen jetzt weiter
mit diesem wundervollen Video hier so
Leute mal kurz orientieren wir den
nächsten Flug sk44 zwei nachtrom so um
15 Uhr jetzt ist gerade 13:44 Uhr gehe
auf jeden Fall jetzt schon mal zum Geld
aber das Gute ist ich habe mir zum
ersten Mal in meinem Leben eine Lounge
gebucht also ich habe keine Kreditkarte
oder so wo mich da rein kann die habe
ich mir allerdings auch bestellt weil
ich ja jetzt auch unterwegs bin und ich
hoffe ich finde die jetzt auch ohne
Probleme und dann schauen wir da mal
rein und ja ich teile euch meinen ersten
Einblick in eine Flughafenlounge in der
ja sämtliches Essen und so weiter und so
fort umsonst ist ich bin gespannt ich
freue mich auf jeden Fall da haben wir
was essen Lounge ich dachte ich suche
mir jetzt hier einen Ast aber ich habe
schnell gefunden ich hoffe ich komme
nicht so ohne Probleme rein weil ich
habe gar keinen Ticket oder so bekommen
schauen wir mal also Leute ich bin in
die Lounge und ich muss sagen die war
ziemlich voll das hat mich ein bisschen
überrascht aber gut kein Problem
deswegen bin ich daran auch nicht mit
der Kamera rumgelaufen weil ich wollte
die Leute auch in Ruhe lassen ich habe
es ein bisschen für euch mit gefilmt ich
habe mir erstmal schön ein paar Brötchen
geholt und eine Suppe und ein Keks der
war super lecker da habe ich das schon
ausgelötet und mir noch eine nächste
Runde geholt danach habe ich mich dann
ein bisschen auf die Lounge gesetzt mir
noch einen Kaffee gezogen und habe
einfach mal mies abgechillt also
launches an Flughäfen sind wirklich
super krass also ich bin echt entsetzt
dass ich das nicht eher entdeckt habe
kann ich eben nur ans Herz legen denn
ein bisschen entspannter reisen möchte
und ja ich habe mich eine Stunde oder ca
aufgehalten und muss sie schon weiter
denn der nächste Flug hat gewartet nach
Tromso ach keine Ahnung die richtige
Aussprache ist drüben so okay ich habe
mich jetzt eine Dreiviertelstunde
aufgehalten es war unfassbar entspannt
also ich bin echt froh wenn meine
Kreditkarte da ist weil ab jetzt mache
ich das immer ich habe jetzt für die
Lautstärke einmalig 29 € bezahlt aber
sonst ist das kostenlos bzw mit der
Kreditkarte die kostet dann 50 60 € im
Monat aber für mich wenn ich jetzt immer
unterwegs bin lohnt sich das Zelt aber
jetzt ab zum Geld ab nach Tromso wir
haben nämlich schon
[Musik]
ich glaube es ist arschkalt
es geht Leute ich bin angekommen so der
erste Eindruck geisteskrank wirklich
guckt euch das mal an überall Schnee
jetzt erstmal ins Hotel weil wir haben
heute noch einiges vor
[Musik]
kurz erstmal sammeln und dann mache ich
mein kleines Update aber ich muss sagen
echt ich bin richtig überrascht von ich
glaube ich habe ja wirklich schon viel
gesehen von der Welt aber so der erste
Eindruck hat mich noch nie so geflasht
wie hier jetzt
Zimmer an
zack
Bett ja schöner Ausblick typisch
norwegisch glaube ich reicht Badezimmer
moin moin ich habe mich heute auf jeden
Fall hier für einen drei Sterne Hotel
entschieden Norwegen ist ja auch Arsch
teuer ich habe gerade für das Taxi wir
sind glaube ich 9 Minuten gefahren 25 €
bezahlt oder sogar noch ein bisschen
mehr und das Hotel hier hat mich 85 €
gekostet also eigentlich geht's fit die
Taxifahrerin hat mir gerade auch schon
super viel von Tromso Tromso wie auch
immer man es ausspricht ich muss es mir
noch mal anhören weil ich weiß ihr
meckert immer wenn ich irgendwie eine
Aussprache verkacke tut mir leid sie hat
mir auf jeden Fall schon einiges von
Tromsö sie hat mir auf jeden Fall schon
einiges von Triumph so erzählt ich bin
immer ein riesen Fan von so Bootstouren
also immer wenn ich irgendeine Stadt
Besuche dass man da halt so eine
Hafenrundfahrt oder Boots zu macht wenn
es sich halt anbietet und hier mit
diesen ganzen Fjorden geht das schon man
kann sogar Wale anschauen nur aktuell
ist wohl nicht die Zeit dafür das Wale
hier rumschwimmen super schade weil ich
habe mich da richtig drauf gefreut ich
werde jetzt sofort zum Hafen gegangen
aber ich bin trotzdem richtig halbiert
zu sein wir haben jetzt 5 Uhr hier ist
es noch super hell und das Ding ist hier
wird es auch nicht dunkel zumindest in
der Wetter App geht die Sonne zwar für
zwei Stunden unter steht da aber die
Taxifahrer meinte gerade zu mir
eigentlich ist es durchgehend hell also
ich bin einfach mal gespannt und ich
will auf jeden Fall so um 23 Uhr mal
draußen rum Steppen mitten in der Nacht
bei richtigen hellen Tageslicht in einer
Woche ist hier die midnight-stand dann
ist es komplett wirklich 24/7 hell also
die Sonne ist am Himmel und er kurz
einmal ausruhen und dann geht's nach
draußen und ich bin mal gespannt was ich
hier so erlebe ich war zum Glück so
schlau und habe meine Winterjacke
mitgenommen deswegen habe ich jetzt halt
auch angezogen
hinter mir oder ganz hinten ist auf
jeden Fall diese Einkaufsstraße aber ich
wollte jetzt erstmal zum Hafen gehen um
mir vielleicht noch eine Boot zu buchen
das sieht echt so verrückt aus ne also
mit dem Berg und diesem Hafen okay das
ist ja nicht der Hafen der ist irgendwo
da auf jeden Fall ein süßes Örtchen
so hier habe ich jetzt einen Hafner
erreicht kommt gerade ein cooles Schiff
an dieser Stelle jetzt noch das wäre
toll ich habe natürlich auch wieder vor
ein lokales Gericht hier zu essen und
ein traditionelles Bier zu trinken das
Bier machen heute Abend das lokale
Gericht ich schwöre diesmal wirklich
würde ich morgen machen weil ich heute
richtig Bock auf Burger habe und
Skandinavien ist einfach super crazy
also die können richtig gute Burger ich
habe mir den besten Laden hier
rausgesucht dann schauen wir uns gleich
mal an aber erstmal
okay also hier ist sowas von Information
irgendwie ist alles gut
ich glaube so
irgendwie haben die hier schon alle
Feierabend ah 10 Uhr es gibt noch also
so wie es ausschaut gibt es nur eine
Boots zu aktuell und die ist immer um 10
Uhr morgens geht allerdings fünf Stunden
lang also ich muss jetzt nicht 5 Stunden
auf dem Boot zu sein ich wollte einmal
so rumschippern schade eigentlich weil
im Internet schon dass dieses Schiff bis
23 Uhr fährt aber aktuell wohl nicht
touristation sonst muss ich halt
irgendwas anderes machen
no no
alles zu hier also ich will ja nichts
sagen wir haben 5:45 Uhr in Deutschland
hätte noch alles auf na ja wir gehen
jetzt auf jeden Fall zu Burger da haben
die das eh vergessen im Namen
Ute oh das ist aber weit naja egal da
laufe ich jetzt hin oh wir haben schon
6:45 Uhr okay ich nehme alles zurück das
wusste ich nicht wir sind jetzt auf
jeden Fall auf der Haupt Einkaufsstraße
oder im Skaters ich weiß nicht so ganz
also man muss auf jeden Fall sagen es
ist komplett wirklich komplett anders
als jeder Ort an dem ich sonst schon
gewesen bin allein schon wieder dieses
Bild hier so mit den Häusern links und
rechts da vorne ist Burger King und dann
dahinter diese Berge absolut verrückt
naja mir gefällt's also gerade scheint
die Sonne noch auf mein Gesicht mal
gucken ob das heute Nacht auch noch so
ist und ich weiß nicht ob man es
erkennen kann aber da vorne sind
wirklich gerade Leute im Wasser und ich
denke mal das Wasser hat so ja keine
Ahnung 7 8 Grad mutig finde ich gut das
einzige was hier wohl 24/7 Studio na da
muss ich jetzt nicht unbedingt hin
zumindest nicht hier in Deutschland gehe
ich ja auch wieder zum Sport und macht
da ein bisschen aber hier ist sich jetzt
lieber ein Burger ich bin mal gespannt
wie teuer das ist also der Burger und so
wir schauen mal ob ich danach einen soll
wenn es Antrag stellen muss weil ich
denke mal so irgendwas zwischen 20 und
35 € kommt er auf mich zu ah so ja
[Musik]
richtig richtig gut okay Leute Burger
war auf jeden Fall ziemlich lecker 8,5
von 10 gibt's da ich habe schon bessere
gegessen so einen Kopenhagen oder
Stockholm aber der war auf jeden Fall
stabil jetzt gehe ich noch ein
Supermarkt danach musst du Insolvenz
anmelden aber gerade umgerechnet 27 €
kostet ich würde sagen ungefähr doppelt
so viel wie in Deutschland so heißen die
übrigens die Supermärkte und da gehe ich
jetzt mal rein brauchen nämlich
Zahnpasta habe ich vergessen okay Leute
Bier und Zahnpasta zusammen 7 €
schon teuer ne aber egal man muss sagen
die Norweger sind alle super nett und
die sprechen komplett fließend Englisch
das hilft auf jeden Fall in vielen
Situation
weiter weil ich z.B jetzt manchmal in
Polen ein bisschen
Verständigungsprobleme hatte aber gut
mein Englisch ist jetzt auch nicht so
wild also in Tromso sind auf jeden Fall
Möwen wie Tauben guck mal alles voll
damit wobei an sich hatte ich auch
lieber Möwen in Deutschland an so
Bahnhöfen und so als taub oder wäre doch
besser naja Möwen trommelnische Tauben
mein Plan ist jetzt übrigens folgender
ich werde jetzt ins Hotel zurückgehen
werde mir da Fußball angucken Champions
League Spiel deswegen habe ich mir auch
das Spiel gekauft nicht dass ihr denkt
ich trink immer Bier oder so das stimmt
gar nicht aber danach werden wir dann in
die einzige Bar gehen die heute hier in
Tromso auf hat Tromso sorry und mal so
schauen was da geht und da ist es ja
noch von daher bin gespannt wie
angekommen im Hotelzimmer ich muss noch
mal kurz was erläutern ich mag Bier sehr
gerne aber man sollte Alkohol nicht
verherrlichen an die Jungen von euch
Bier erst ab 16 oder besser als 18
früher habe ich ja wirklich nie so
Alkohol thematisiert in meinem YouTube
Videos aber mittlerweile macht das ja
eigentlich jeder und ich will auch keine
Rücksicht mehr drauf nehmen von euch
lass das einfach bei mir ist es so wenn
ich Fußball gucke mit Freund zusammen
trinken wir mal ein Bierchen und ja ich
gehe gleich auch noch mal in der Bar und
trink da vermutlich auch eins aber so
ist das normal an die Diamanten Problem
haben es tut mir leid wir haben jetzt
19:47 Uhr und sehen uns in 4 Stunden
wieder dann ist es 23 Uhr und dann werde
ich wieder nach draußen Steppen und mal
gucken ob es da noch ist ey Leute man
steht hier guckt nach draußen wir haben
mittlerweile Viertel nach 11 Uhr und es
ist so komisch weil ich bin schon leicht
müde bin ja auch den ganzen Tag schon
unterwegs bin heute um 6:30 Uhr
aufgestanden und so aber es ist halt
einfach noch vollkommen hell ich wollte
jetzt vier Stunden keine timelaps machen
deswegen habe ich immer Fotos gemacht zu
jeder Stunde die Blende ich euch hier
mal jetzt hintereinander ein aber wir
machen uns jetzt auf dem Weg und gehen
raus die Sonne ist jetzt offiziell
untergegangen schon vor einiger Zeit
also man sieht sie zumindest nicht mehr
und in der Woche sieht man sie dann
jetzt auch noch aber ist halt trotzdem
jetzt kann man ja verstehen oder auf
geht's in die beste Bar die soll ganz
cool sein ich habe jetzt schon aufs
Handy umgesetzt weil ich habe keinen
Bock mit der fetten Kamera jetzt rum zu
laufen das ist auch uncool und so Bars
und mal gucken ob noch irgendwas geht
let's go also ich muss auch sagen es ist
noch relativ viel los sogar hier auf den
Straßen für mich fühlt es sich so an als
hätten wir irgendwie
ja 19 Uhr aber es ist ja schon viel
später also eigentlich könnte ich jetzt
in Deutschland schlafen gehen oder würde
ich jetzt so verrückt er wirklich sofort
also belebt ist es hier auf jeden Fall
tun wir jetzt noch was bei seven eleven
der mittlerweile da oben ist eine Uhr
für die Leute die mir nicht glauben da
kann man sehen halb zwölf also es ist
wirklich nachts also Leute wir haben
jetzt ein bisschen nach 12 ich bin hier
noch ein bisschen rumgesteppt hier kann
man jetzt glaube ich auch sehen dass es
spät ist also hier ist niemand mehr es
ist noch ein bisschen dunkler geworden
aber es ist trotzdem schon hell also ich
würde in Deutschland jetzt denken ist
ungefähr so als würde jetzt jeden Moment
die Sonne aufgehen das tut sie auch
gleich also jetzt zu der Zeit wo ich
hier war war die Sonne offiziell zwei
Stunden weg dieser Besuch hier hat auf
jeden Fall meine Vorstellung von allem
was man so besuchen kann noch mal
erweitert hat falls man das so
ausdrücken kann ich habe zwar vor zwei
oder drei Jahren mal so wirklich
erfahren dass es Städte gibt auch in
Europa wo es wirklich zu bestimmten
Jahreszeiten komplett 24/7 helles aber
das dann wirklich mal hautnah mitzuleben
ist schon crazy also man fühlt sich
wirklich komplett anders ich habe auch
eben mit so Leuten an der Bar gesprochen
die meinen auch für dieses ist halt
normal aber die können verstehen dass
sich das ein bisschen komisch finde aber
auf jeden Fall richtig coole Stadt ist
eine Erfahrung wert man kann zwar nicht
so viel machen also hier gibt es ein
paar Studenten die haben zwei Bars wo
die hingehen können tun mir auch ein
bisschen leid mehr gehe ich halt nicht
zumindest habe ich das sonst nicht
rausgefunden falls noch irgendwie ein
Club hier auf ist oder so würde ich auch
safe machen aber gibt's halt nicht bis
morgen vielleicht oder vielleicht
passiert noch was keine Ahnung da ist
übrigens wieder die Sauna was die Taxi
fahren meinte aber ich glaube da gehe
ich jetzt nicht ins Wasser oder aber
halt auch kein Handtuch dabei mist ich
bleibe jetzt hier 5 Minuten stehen und
wenn die Tür von der Sauna gleich noch
aufgeht und dann noch Leute sind dann
gehe ich dahin okay versprochen ich
schwöre da kam jemand mehr aus der Sauna
ich habe aber noch einen guten Vergleich
wie man sich fühlt damit es vielleicht
viele von euch verstehen können ich
fühle mich wie als ich mit 18 um 6 Uhr
morgens im Sommer aus dem Club
rausgestellt hat bin und die Sonne kurz
mal aufgehen war so fühlt sich das an
nur halt ohne diesen Alkohol- ja so kann
man sich das vorstellen guten Morgen
Leute ich bin gerade wach geworden
schauen wir doch mal ob es schon ist
hahaha
so fertig gemacht Rucksack an ich muss
auch schon wieder auschecken aus dem
Hotel wir gehen auf jeden Fall jetzt
hier im Grimm so ach ich kann kommen ich
lasse es einfach ich glaube seitdem ich
das Video angefangen habe habe ich
diesen Namen zehnmal anders
ausgesprochen jetzt noch was
norwegisches essen und dann steht für
mich eine nachtzugfahrt an aber dazu
gibt's natürlich neues Video schauen mal
was der Tag heute bringt let's go
auf jeden Fall erstmal ein Cappuccino
hier in dieser kleinen süßen Backstube
und was zu Essen habe ich mir auch schon
geholt guten Appetit so Leute ich wollte
jetzt noch hier ins susets garden
restaurant da werde ich auch gern
gestern schon reingegangen ist direkt am
Wasser ich verstehe nichts na ja wird
schon passen
[Musik]
also ich habe gerade mir die Karte
angeschaut und ich habe gesehen hier
gibt's einfach Wahl Fleisch
Alter das nehme ich aber nicht
vielleicht schwimmt 15 Sandwich
[Musik]
ich habe mich hier auf jeden Fall für
die Backe blau entschieden nur im
Internet war das irgendwie anders aus
aber es ist glaube ich traditionell
[Musik]
das war jetzt zwar ganz lecker aber hat
mich nicht so umgehauen ich bin jetzt
auch nicht so der Typ der viel Fisch ist
trotzdem war es an sich ganz lecker und
ich denke ein halbwegs guter Abschluss
ich gehe jetzt noch ein bisschen hier
spazieren würde das Video aber an dieser
Stelle beenden hier auch noch mal also
die Boote fahren heute alle wieder nicht
die fahren wohl erst wieder im Juni bin
ich leider im Monat zu früh hier aber
gut kann man nichts machen trotzdem was
eine richtig geile Erfahrung und ich
werde hier auf jeden Fall auch noch mal
wieder kommen wenn es 24 Stunden
durchgehen dunkel ist weil dann gibt's
ja auch die Polarlichter und dann fahren
auf jeden Fall auch die Boote zur Polar
night Expedition oder so abonniert den
Kanal für weitere Reisevideos sieht auf
jeden Fall einiges in Zukunft kommen
macht mir sehr viel Spaß würde ich mich
drüber freuen und wir sehen uns Leute
haut rein ciao